with regards with regards to the
universities I thought at one point that
the best thing to do would be to cut
their funding by 25% let them fight
amongst themselves for the remnants
because it would force the universities
to decide exactly what's important and
what isn't so I would say the humanities
and much of the social sciences has
turned into a postmodern neo-marxist
playground for radicals the scholarship
is terrible 80% of humanities papers
aren't cited once once and so what that
means is that they write papers for each
other and they sell them to libraries
and that's how the publishers make their
money and no one reads them but the
publishers can print them because the
libraries have to buy them and they're
buying them with your tax money and so
all of you who are sitting here are
funding an postmodern radical
neo-marxist agenda that has its roots in
the university and your tax money is
going towards that and if you want proof
of that you just go online and look at
the websites especially of disciplines
like women's studies which is
pathological right to the core but it's
not just women's studies it's all the
ethnic studies groups
it's anthropology its sociology its
social work and most of all its
education and oisi for example in
Ontario is perhaps apart from the
Ontario Human Rights Commission the most
dangerous institution in Canada it
should it should be defunded it's as
simple as that they don't do the
research they purport to do they're not
interested in in in at all in education
they're interested in the indoctrination
of people as young as they can fun as
the young as they can get their hands on
so to speak now we need to figure out
our society needs to figure out how to
stop shunting public tax money to
radical left-wing activists if we were
doing that for radical right-wing
activists there would be an absolute
storm but it's happened incrementally
since the 1960s and it needs to stop